democrats utterly clueless on how to
solve the crime wave they unleashed so
they just keep blaming the pandemic in
chicago there was yet another brazen
smash and grab robbery caught on camera
thieves ransacking a luxury car
dealership in broad daylight stealing
millions of dollars of items the owner
of that showroom blasting the city's
liberal leaders
this happened in broad daylight on
saturday
and they have
people come and break into your store
while while while there's customer
shopping and there's children in there i
never realized that that it has got to
such a
boiling point
and there's no one stepping out to say
anything about it
and as new york city suffers through a
massive spike in violence outgoing mayor
bill de blasio perhaps making the most
foolish statement of his time in office
eight years i've been mayor
index crime major crimes in new york
city down 11 percent over eight years
and we did it bringing police and
community closer together look around
the city right now this city is thriving
the bottom line is that there is to
today in new york city a much safer city
than we were eight years ago there's no
question about that
bite me grave what do you say
double bite me i think if you get double
bits you're more than immune from that
idiot uh i don't know where he's
obviously he's stoned 90 of the time or
because everybody here knows intimately
somebody who's been a victim of a crime
or has been a victim of a crime it's
nothing like this he he's talking about
index crime meaning that he lumps them
all together so he lowers the average
while murder skyrockets so think about
this
he can say
muggings are down because the mugger
killed the victim
right that's exactly what he's saying
personally i would like more muggings
with less murder right do you see that
do you see the logic here that the only
reason why buggings are down is because
they killed the person
you know what the the worst part about
this is how do you fight how do you
fight crimes when the political leaders
in the media who coddle the criminals
and deny that crime exist i'm worried at
this point
that there's a sense of hopelessness and
acceptance that has set in when you're
doing this kind of like mumbo jumbo when
you hear about another shopkeeper who
was up uptown getting stabbed because
the guy wanted a free cigarette or
something he was stabbed to death last
night then you have an elderly asian
that was shot dead in chicago on the
streets and you go
in your head you go but
what can you do right what can you do
and then you go back and you look at
your box scores or you look at your
stocks that's everybody in the media
everybody in the media is now reporting
this stuff as mundane and as acceptable
almost making us all guilty we should be
out on the streets it's a shame that
none of us protest because we're you
know we got a good life but this is
worth protesting it's insane we know
people
it i know i hear stories from friends
every day now yeah somebody getting
mugged uh
right you know robbed uh stabbed dana
but then at least the new mayor here in
new york city is speaking out against uh
the bail reform says it's cr you know
it's
not his words but it's crazy that people
are just you know
commit a crime and right back out on the
street could he individually change it
turn it around because people are angry
enough about it well there's a huge
amount of hope in eric adams and so the
mayor comes with um with everybody
pulling for him but really hoping to see
something pretty quickly i recently was
told of a
event that he went to or a lunch where
they said um
he said he was wanted feedback what is
what could be done in the city to make
reinvestment a thing make sure that all
these empty storefronts get filled again
and he said now don't tell me about
homeless and crime because i got that i
got it it's going to be changed i'm on
top of it let's now talk about the
business community that might be the
right attitude to be helpful for him but
you know who else should help him the
biden administration they have an
opportunity to try to back a new
democratic black mayor in a city that is
super important not only to our nation's
economy but to the world's economy and
this is a wonderful state with some
really good people they should come in
and figure out a way to help him and
maybe help themselves in the process
because the white house has continued to
point to covet as the reason crime is up
when actually you actually you see um
eugene robinson writing today
and i believe clarence page
also wrote today that that
soft on crime prosecutors are a problem
right in the city councils and the
the uh
the governors in these states and the
legislatures but here's what jinsaki
had to say when she was asked about
crime herald get your response listen to
this
what i will tell you is we have seen an
increase in crime over the course of the
pandemic there are a range of reasons
for that
and what we're our focus is on is what
we can do to address it the president
has proposed additional funding in the
budget to make sure local police
departments and cops have the funding
they need
well instead of giving concrete answers
and reaching sending out you know help
for new york she serves up a bowl of
gruel that she fully expects the media
to lap up
well i think when you we talked about
protesting and i think the real protest
we saw here in new york voters elected
eric adams eric adams position on crime
his position on community engagement his
position on putting police officers back
in communities perhaps even undercover
fully funding and now to your point
digging reforming bail reform i think
that's the message that the majority of
democrats i know and i know a lot of
them that's where we are on this issue
and i would even argue that moderate
democrats and even some of my moderate
republican friends are right where he is
i think the president's probably going
to have to speak more specifically and
concretely about the ways in which the
federal government will partner with
cities be it chiefs of police in chicago
all across texas for that matter all
across the country i saw the former
mayor of philadelphia michael nutter be
very critical of the d.a there in
philadelphia there is no question that
there are a number of da's that are
elected across the country who've
adopted a coddling criminal enabling
crime kind of position i think it came
from a good place we still got to search
and articulate what that good place is
but they've got a fig they've got to
understand that what they
thought they were achieving in a
positive way is not working it's
creating more crime it's creating more
violence it's creating more unsafe areas
in cities all across the country and the
people who generally are hurt the most
by this
are people in the middle class and
people who are not in the middle class
beneath it
and when police officers don't show up
when the cops are called the communities
that hurt the most are the ones we want
to protect the most so
i hope they change this and i hope the
white house and others are partners with
eric adams and others across the country
who want to do these things yep this the
liberal lunacy isn't going to disappear
though jesse there's a billboard over on
the west side highway about we need to
the problem is in the prisons free them
all it says free them all so that that's
not disappearing i wonder if the fact
that california emptied the jails for
kovid had anything to do with the rise
in smash and grabs in california i think
it has a little bit to do with that we
had the jewelry thief ex-jewelry thief
on waters world over the weekend
he says he thinks a lot of these smash
and grab crews or gang initiations you
know they used to have to have someone
beat you up in order to join the gang
now you're just going to have to be a
member of the heist in order to do it he
thinks it's not drug addicts it's not
low down scale people these people have
nice footwear all black masks they've
obviously cased the joint case the joint
is lingo thank you thievery you say all
black
are you sure that's what you meant of
course
and they go in and they're highly
organized because each one knows where
the other one is going if you notice at
the end they all go into different
directions so that way you can't pinch
more than one at the same time pinch is
also afraid thank you and some of these
that i've been watching
and so also a lot of times they don't
even use a gun during the heist because
if you get caught with a firearm that's
an additional seven to nine years or
something like that and then they link
in the click yes and they uh
and they line up a lot of the buyers for
all these luxury goods ahead of time so
usually you get like that shuffled out
of your hands quickly on the black
market or the internet why are you
black market is what the illegal
underground market illicit underground
trade in stolen goods okay thank you
maybe take about 10 off of the louis or
something like that yes um but a lot of
it has to do too with to fund the police
the first thing they cut were these
informants or these undercover units so
stools stoolies yes um yes
or rats
um and so they the police departments
have no idea any of this stuff is coming
they don't have the ear to the streets
yeah like like they used to
got to go
what an education you need to do a crime
show on fox station oh how do you know
i'd already have one lined up okay thank
you speaking of insanity covet insanity
not going away as democrats impose new
ridiculous mandates hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else